ah
I'm gonna talk about coffeescript which
is a little language that is written in
itself and compiles to JavaScript so
um I was pretty interested in a lot of
what crockford was just saying a couple
minutes ago over in the other in track a
about all of the sort of deficiencies
and things that people aren't satisfied
with in JavaScript and things that could
have been done better bad parts that
should be left out and you know it
should be kind of like a human right but
for but for coders that you should have
a coder's right to have JavaScript be
the language that you want it to be and
um and because JavaScript has such a
nice clean functional object-oriented
lexically scoped core you can build a
lot of interesting languages on top of
it without having to get too far away
from what the core idea of JavaScript is
so could I get a quick show of hands of
how many of you have played with
coffeescript before
all right so that's a that's a pretty
good mix
um so I'm going to go quickly through
some of the language features
um what it does differently than
JavaScript and then also how it's
implemented if you want to write
something like this for your own
language that would be however however
you saw fit so um let's see here
this talk is going to be pretty rapid
fire it's also just going to be all code
so we can if you have any questions feel
free to raise your hand in the middle
and we can change things and recompile
it and see see how it works
um so so there's kind of three main
aspects to the idea of of doing this you
know there's a lot of languages I mean I
guess the other so one of the other
really big ones is objective J which
puts Objective C into JavaScript but to
do that you have to have kind of an
entire runtime but the idea here is not
so much to to Port an existing language
like python or Ruby into JavaScript
directly but instead to take the core of
JavaScript and to clean out all the
syntax that you know looks like Java but
you don't really need and to also clean
up some of the semantics so things like
VAR how you know you have to use VAR the
first time you declare the variable
never again thereafter and you almost
always need to use it the first time
because you don't want it to be Global
so things like that go away things like
like statements go away everything is an
expression in coffeescript so you can
pass the result of an if statement
directly back to you can assign to a
variable you can pass it back to a
callback that sort of thing so that's
the second aspect we have the we have
the cleaned up syntax we have we have
cleaned up semantics and there's also
extra goodies so language features like
slices Splats that's the very attic
arguments that uh that crocod was
talking about before
you have comprehensions instead of
low-level loops and all all kinds of
extra goodies that we can there's some
things that you can't do like Brian was
just talking about like with method
missing you can't do that without
actually either having an interpreter or
having uh you know or intercepting every
single object call that you ever do so
those kinds of some things that are just
impossible but the things that we can do
we try to so
um the gold so that that brings us to
the golden rule is that it's just
JavaScript it's not it's not uh it's not
a runtime it's not an interpreter
there's no special functions really
allowed and that's a rule we break
slightly um but but we're not going to
be injecting a whole bunch of
coffeescript specific Library functions
into your code in general it just
translates into the equivalent
JavaScript
um so it leaves a lot of things out it
is a smaller language than JavaScript is
you don't have with you don't have
semicolons or semicolon insertion to
deal with in your parsing you don't have
to worry about trailing commas there's
no difference between the colon inside
of the object to assign a property
versus variable assignment outside
syntax wise no implicit Global variables
because that's taking care of for you
you don't even have to worry about low
level for Loops because instead you have
comprehensions and if you really really
need the low level Loop you can use a
while so that's the one that we do
Expose and that can be that's generally
have to be transformed into into
anything else and no difference between
ternaries and if else's right so in
JavaScript you have an if else that's a
statement you can't return that value
but return area is an expression and you
can and there's no real reason that they
need to be two separate things so let's
start with the basic
um
basically a function so here you have a
JavaScript function it's it's assigned
to a variable named Square it's also
named so that if you need to debug it
you'll actually have a name and we'll
just say Anonymous and you're going to
return you take in a number X you return
x times x and that's that's you know
JavaScript 101. so if we were going to
transform this into coffeescript what
would that look like well first off you
don't need the semicolon because
why bother second you don't need to
declare your your VAR you can just
assign it
we can we can use and this is kind of up
to your style the preferred coffeescript
styles to use colons to assign
um all over the place instead of equals
but they are interchangeable so you can
use equal signs instead of objects
inside of objects as well so we'll
switch this over to a colon
um returns are implicit inside of a
function the last thing that you the
last expression you evaluate will always
be returned so you don't need to return
it yourself so we'll take that out and
also the semicolon in there it uses
python style block white space syntax so
you don't need to use curlies to limit
your your blocks so we'll take off the
curlies and just use the indentation
there
and finally instead of the function
keyword
um well I guess before we get to that
um we have square repeated twice and
which always looks very redundant so
let's take off one of those squares and
finally instead of the function keyword
what a function looks like is just an
arrow pointing from the arguments to the
result so we have square is a function
of X and it goes to x times x and now
that's highlighted as a function and you
can also write that on one line like
this
so you can see how that got transformed
square is a function that takes in X and
it returns x times x
so that's a good example and uh actually
let's give this a try so this text made
us hooked up and there's a there's a
text made bundle there's a there's an
emacs bundle there's a Vim bundle
there's bundles for all your needs this
one's hooked up so we can compile this
and see what it turns into
so here we have it back looking more or
less like it did the the Declaration got
pushed up to the top but you have back
your JavaScript function and if we run
that let's say puts
the square of 100
and we get oops I have to do the whole
thing let's do this we get back ten
thousand
all right
so um it it the sort of the mo is to not
change anything about JavaScript that's
already you know very clear and very
common it's not just changing it for
changes sake so so arrays look the same
object literals look the same those are
both very nicely done you can see how
we're using the same assignment syntax
elements is an object literal that has
hydrogen silicon and uranium properties
with if you because it has because we
are white space sensitive if you do your
assignments on multiple lines you don't
have to worry about commas you can leave
them off you can put them in you can
have trailing commas it's all going to
compile to the same thing so actually
let's do that we compile this to
JavaScript
and we'll get our commas and you can see
even if you have them and it's trailing
it's not going to be trailing when you
compile it to JavaScript so I won't
won't kill you on that
and uh and property accessing is the
same it's dot properties so we can say
puts elements.silicon
and we're going to get back 14.
all right
on to the next one so this is the white
space for Block syntax that I showed you
before it of course looks more more
python-e when it gets more nested so
here's an if here's a block if statement
if answer is yes and attempts is less
than three then we have a try catch
try try again catch error report error
and if we look at what this compiles to
in JavaScript just to get a sense of how
the white space is working
it's going to look like this
so you can see how your try catch block
got translated and all the curlies got
inserted and this also shows some
aliases that that you have so all of the
JavaScript operators greater than less
than triple equals stuff is available
but you also have aliases so yes yes
um yes no on off are aliases for true
false like they are in yaml so you can
write things out a little bit more
naturally if you're depending on what
your wording is for your booleans and
then also is and isn't for triple equals
and not not triple equals
um
which is nice too
so a lot of things that are available in
Block syntax form like this are also
available in postfix prefix or postfix
so here we have if ignition is on block
launch rocket or you could say launch
rocket if ignition is on and if we
compile this snippet right here
we can see that I guess in in one case
it became the ternary and the other one
it's uh it's the actual block if but
they're doing the same thing
if ignition is true then you launch the
rocket otherwise you don't
and then the same thing for the same
thing is true for basically for anything
where you have a where you have an
indented block you can also do a prefix
if it's just a single line expression so
here we're doing a comprehension so for
every song in repertoire we're going to
sing it and then this is the same form
but uh but written out as a block
all right
um so getting getting past the sort of
the syntax subtractions the you know all
the semicolons and and punctuation noise
towards the expression stuff which I
think so I think that everything's an
expression is probably the single most
important feature of of all of this it
definitely changes the most in how your
code is structured
um so here we have a comprehension
you're going to print out I 4i in that
array in one two three and so this is
this is an example of running a function
call you know n times or I times
for that entire statement so if we run
that we're going to get one two three oh
I just rang the entire file sorry
we're going to get one two three
but you can also so if you wrap if you
wrap the comprehension in parentheses or
if you call the comprehension or you
return it or you assign it to a variable
it's going to be converted into an
expression for you and so what that
means is is that as we're generating the
code we we look at the comprehension and
we say is it being used is it being
returned is it being assigned to and if
it is then it gets converted into the
result of the computation every single
time through the comprehension so it's
just to be familiar to you if you've
used python before or um
but it's basically the equivalent of
doing an each or a select or a filter
um
so you are taking you're you're applying
the you're applying the block of code
for every time through the loop and then
you're taking the array of results and
you're turning that array so here we're
going to print out
um
one two three as an array I guess P will
make that more clear because P will
inspect that
so now we'll see one two three as an
array as the result of this and so
internally what it's doing is it's is
it's pushing the result of every time
through onto an array and then returning
that when it's done
um so but this works exactly identically
for um for anything else so here we're
going to put a try catch block directly
into puts
and so if we run that we're going to try
to call a property on a missing object
this object is not defined it doesn't
exist and then catch the error and then
print that out
so we have
the error is reference error missing is
not defined
um
and so internally what happens is
basically every every single node in the
grammar knows how to return itself so
you can ask it to basically if you're an
if and it and you're being asked to
return it'll return all it'll return
from any of the branches that it goes
into if you're a a for loop I mean if
you're if you're a comprehension you're
asked to be returned you're going to
return the results of going through the
array if you're a try catch you're going
to return the either the try or the
catch depending on what gets fired and
So based on that
um anytime you need to convert an
expression a JavaScript expression into
a I mean sorry a JavaScript statement
into an expression you can wrap it in a
closure so if you wrap it in a closure
and then you return the result now you
have something that used to be a
statement but instead it can be used in
expression so that's what's going on
internally there
the other thing that I didn't mention
that this demonstrates is um this isn't
being syntax highlighted in this but we
have string interpolation as is proposed
in ecmascript harmony
um one really fun place to mine for
language ideas is there's an ecmascript
Harmony Wiki that has a whole bunch of
things that they're thinking about
putting into the next version of
JavaScript and this is one of the
proposals
um
this is just a quick little demo of how
the VAR works so you might have noticed
that we're not declaring VAR um at all
but what ends up happening is that your
your when you when you first use a
variable when you first assign to a
variable its VAR declaration is going to
get pushed up to the top of the nearest
lexical scope so in this case a is going
to have you know the equivalent of VAR a
out here because it was first even
though it's being referenced in the same
exact way inside the function it was
first reference outside and then B will
have a VAR B inside the function it
won't be visible from the outside scope
so that's how that's handled for you
what it means is that you can't you
can't Shadow variables inside of a
function of the same name you're always
going to be referring to the outside
variable and that's similar to languages
like Ruby inside of blocks if you refer
to a variable the same name it's always
going to be the outside one so you have
to pick a different name if you actually
mean a different variable because there
isn't a VAR for you
and I think that's a that's a worthwhile
trade-off the other way isn't workable
at all if everything Shadows then you
can't get anything done
um
here's another example of a of a cleanup
um It We Fix JavaScript switch statement
so
um so I guess we have a longer example
of what it looks like these are the same
sort of implicit blocks you can say when
Mo then do an action or you can indent
it like this is equivalent
but switches internally compile into if
else chains using object identity to
match instead of a JavaScript switch
case statement because JavaScript switch
cases are implemented using labels you
can only do string comparisons you can't
compare anything that's not a string and
if you do it'll coerce it and then also
you have to stick and break after every
uh
after every case we don't want to fall
through so so instead of doing that this
becomes an if else so we can put this
back the way it was
and give it a try so if we run this
actually nothing will happen so then
let's call so which dude which dude is a
function that switches on stooge when
it's mode and it says it's Mo when it's
curly and this is using actual objects
not strings so let's say puts which
is huge
curly and let's run this file and we'll
have it's currently I'm sorry it was
already put saying we can just say which
dudes curly
we can do the same thing for MO
and let's look at what it compiles into
so we have our we have our two objects
and you can see how
we have our function it's a named
function
if Stooges Mo then we return that value
you can see how the returns are getting
pushed into each into each statement so
because the switch that's a good example
because the switch was the last thing
that happened inside the function you're
always going to return a value no matter
what you do
let's see it's 10 22. all right
um here's that string interpolation so
uh
we have
um dollar sign and uh and so this this
is exactly the same as the proposed
Harmony syntax dollar sign literal or
you can do literal.property just gets
interpolated directly
um and then you can with dollar sign
with brackets you can do arbitrary
Expressions inside of your interpolation
so let's say Jeremy
uh name is Jeremy
there you go
and
um one thing that we add is a Python's
chain comparisons so if you have more
than one greater than less than
comparison in a row it's going to do the
correct order of operations to to make
that value work so healthy as if your
cholesterol is less than 200 and more
than 60. so healthy 133 is going to be
true and healthy 40 is going to be false
and what's going on under the scenes
behind the scenes here is this gets
converted into
200 is greater and cholesterol is
greater than 60. and so this is one of
those cases um where if you're doing
something like this in your own language
you have to be careful if you ever have
to reference a variable multiple times
to um to compute a result you have to be
careful that you don't call if for
example if if what's going on here is a
function call that you don't call the
function twice because then that could
have side effects and could do something
you don't want it to do so the way we
get around that is if cholesterol is
actually a function call here and you
compile that what's going to happen is
you're going to get a temporary variable
assigned to cholesterol and then
referenced in the later one so you don't
have to so it doesn't get called twice
and that that's the case in general for
for something where you need to have
multiple references to an expression
that you don't want to evaluate more
than once is we'll do a temporary
variable
in the output JavaScript so um
really quickly
um besides we saw the array
comprehensions before where you're
saying I in a list of numbers but you
can also do it for objects so it's for
it's for um
sorry so for a number in a list of
numbers or for key comma value of an
object so in this case we're going to
look at all the keys and this is so this
is all being powered by node.js on the
back end so we're looking at all the
keys in the process object which is the
one of the global objects that you have
and you're going to get back your big
list of
of node signals and such
and so that's an object comprehension
and of course you can have a block
inside of that doing however much code
you need to do and then there's also
range comprehensions so instead of
having to write out if you if you're if
you're if your for Loop was just going
to be um numbers and you're going to
start at zero and go up to a certain
amount instead of that you can use a
range literal this is the same as Ruby's
range literal more or less so two dots
is is uh inclusive of the final value
and three dots is exclusive and so this
is this is going to be the comprehension
of I in 0 to 20. let me take off this by
two for a minute
and then we're going to join it so there
you have from zero up to 20.
um you can you can do steps so we can
say buy two
and that'll give you the even numbers
and you can also do filters so this is
where this is where that select filter
kind of thing comes in so for any
comprehension you can say when and then
you have an arbitrary condition to to
satisfy so in this case let's say when I
mod 2 is 1 and we'll get all the odd
numbers
or out by this when I mod 2 isn't zero
isn't zero
and now we get all the odd numbers
between uh 0 and 20 inclusive
all right I'm gonna try to get through
this um on time so here's a JavaScript
statement again you can tell because the
semicolon so this is something you've
probably done a lot where you have a
default value you want to assign to a
property inside of the beginning of a
function so one of the simplifications
that we do
um you know how you have plus equals and
minus equals and divided by equals in
JavaScript and in languages like Ruby
you would have instead of writing this
you would write or equals
um to say that the options or equals the
default value
um so one thing that we do to get rid of
those you can still use those if you
want to they're present it's it's all
sort of backwards compatible with
JavaScript you can sort of slip into it
easily but the cleaner way to say that
is just assign it to the half expression
so options.value gets or the default
value or you could do gets and
or you could do gets plus and this would
be like doing a plus equals assigning it
to plus the default value
um so let's talk about Splats Splats are
a a nice feature where you know if you
if you have a Splat in your argument
list we'll compile that into the correct
lookup inside of the arguments array to
get back what you need so here we've got
best actor the first argument is going
to be the winner and then every every
next argument is going to be a runner's
up and we're just going to print out who
the winner is and then pass in three
three actors
and you'll get the expected result
and if we look at what that compiles
into you're going to see that we're
going to be so this is one example where
we do have a reference to a special
function just to keep the code shorter
the actual outputting bytes so we make a
cache reference to array prototype slice
and we're going to slice the runners up
to get that
this is kind of a fun one the the
existential operator
um if so so or the the logical or
there's a lot of falsy values in
JavaScript things that like zero the
empty string that uh that you might
that might be confusing to you so if
you're trying to set a default speed for
example
um and you use or if the speed happens
to be zero which is a perfectly valid
speed to have it's going to still get
the default which isn't what you want so
what you really want is you want to say
if it's not undefined and it's not null
you know those are the being the not
exist values then um then use it so the
existential operator which is the
question mark gives you a way to sort of
um to say if it's undefined or if it's
null then you know do one thing or else
do the other thing so in this case if we
leave this the way that it is using or
and run that
you're going to get back
140 let's see go and run just that part
right you're gonna get back 140. but if
we use the existential operator
you're going to get back the correct
value which is going to stay zero
because zero is a valid speed
and so you can use the existential
operator within a property chain if
you're walking down a property chain
this is similar to a soak in groovy
where if that value is undefined that
property is undefined then it's going to
stop and you're going to get back
undefined as the result
um so in this case we can say put
sue.name let's get rid of this
and it's going to say Sue
.name.length does exist
sue.name.length dot other does not and
we'll get back let's see let's keep
going other dot dot 1.2.3
spelled wrong
you get back uh an error but if you want
to soak it up and you want to assign
this often happens and you want to
assign if it doesn't exist then just
give me back undefined and I don't need
to to continue then we can say oh
let's soak up the result of that chain
after other and you're going to get back
undefined instead of the instead of the
big exception
so uh yeah
a Judicial judicious use of uh of soaks
can help clean up your accessing and I'm
gonna try to wrap things up
um there's class literals which uh this
this is basically a lightweight wrapper
around so it's this isn't this isn't
like a full-blown class system with
runtime objects and stuff all this is is
setting up is basically you have an
object literal and you set properties on
an object right you have a class little
you're setting objects on the Prototype
you're sending properties on the
Prototype so that when you make a new
object everything will be set up for you
correctly and so the two extra things
that this lets you do that aren't so
easy in JavaScript is it helps you
correctly extend the Prototype chain
there's a lot of ways to incorrectly
accept extend the Prototype chain where
you're breaking your inheritance and you
can only get one level deep but this
will this this uses something similar to
goog.inherits from the closure Library
if you guys ever check that out
um
to to basically you can have arbitrarily
long inheritance chains with with
everything working correctly including
super so you can call Super and it'll
reference the function of the same name
on the immediate ancestor and you can of
course pass variables to that and do the
super things that are usually tricky to
do without a class library in JavaScript
so here let's say so here we've got a C
Shanty our Mariners we're going to make
a new Mariner and have him sing
make a new Sailor and we can see how
Singh Is overridden this is all you know
oop 101
and then the pirate calls super and then
says R so we'll have the pirate sing
and that's all as expected and uh let's
see I think that's that's getting close
to the end
um I'm gonna wrap things up so in terms
of implementation this uh coffeescript
was first written in Ruby it was a ruby
gem because of course when you start
working on a new language you have to
start with something and but now it's
written entirely in coffeescript so
there was a point where we uh we had a
working Ruby version and then wrote a
coffeescript version that was more or
less parallel had the Ruby version
compiled that and then had the
coffeescript version compile itself and
then now that's where we are so it's
like I guess is that there's that
Wittgenstein saying about pulling up the
ladder after you you know we can't go
back now if if The coffeescript
Interpreter disappears then there's no
way to compile it at this point because
that's that's all that does it so um so
it was using Ruby and rack and rack is a
uh it's a it's a yak style lalr um
parser generator that's uh that's done
in Ruby and sea but so now that we're in
JavaScript it uses Jason which uh Zach
is going to give a talk about shortly I
think it's not the next one but the one
after this which is a nice flexible
JavaScript parser generator so
so that's that's the current mix it's
got a handwritten lecture um done in
coffeescript um it's got a rewriter so
the token stream gets Rewritten before
it actually gets sent to the parser
which is something that lets us get go
beyond
um the sort of basic lalr grammar we're
doing stuff with the with the with the
implicit calls where you can see how
we're saying you know we have we have
calls that don't need parentheses and
then they get matched all the way down
to the end of the of the block
um doing things like that with the with
the significant white space
um
and also the rest of language features
um gets a little bit tricky if you're
trying to fit that into you know this
would seem like it would be a very large
large language to try to fit into a
grammar but if you rewrite the token
stream in advance to remove ambiguities
and things that would be ambiguous if
you decide in advance oh this is the way
that implicit calls work before the
parse before the parser ever sees it
then you can have a much smaller parser
so including including the grammar
including the rewriter including the
lecture it's 1800 1 800 lines of
coffeescript so it's not it's not very
big
um and then and then that and then the
result of the parsing stage is the AST
and then to generate the JavaScript you
just call compile at the top level of
the AST and it all walks down and every
node you know passing information around
compiles the resulting JavaScript output
so all of this is uh available on
coffeescript.org it is uh it is sort of
a fun project it's not it's not supposed
to you know I'm not trying to to sell
you on using it for your next big web
app I think it's fun to play around in
um and the language still might change
until you go to 1.0 I think it's settled
down a lot recently it used to be much
more unstable the first version didn't
have significant white space and then
people were you know talking about it
and we we decided to add it but uh so
the language might still change and
that's the caveat but besides that it is
being used some people are using in
production to do different things
um here's a fun example of someone who's
using it to generate art on their
website so this is using coffeescript
and Raphael to combinatorially combine a
whole bunch of little sketches that he
has going on
and and then I've got a fun example of
this of my own which is
right here so this shows that you don't
really lose you're not going to really
lose any speed from from what JavaScript
would be doing if you do something in
coffeescript because it's going to be a
one-to-one translation so this is V8
powering a strange attractor that we can
uh let's see we can reseed
and draw in different ways
and the and the processing speed of V8
here is is very good it's comparable
actually to the to the Java processing
versions of this same of the same sketch
so again it's all on coffeescript.org
there is an interactive compiler you can
try it'll it'll compile as you type
right here it's running in the browser
there's also the entire annotated Source
right next to that so if you want to
read what the grammar looks like you can
pop over to that and you can check out
what all the rules are so here's
statements Expressions all this kind of
stuff and come talk to me about it after
if you have any more questions and
thanks a lot
foreign